yesterday everyone was talking about a
new game controlled by kisi one person
has a magnet stuck on their tongue and
the position and speed of their tongue
controls the direction and speed of a
bowling ball but until and if that game
hit stores let's wait it out with ten
interactive things that you can play
right now in the description meaty boner
is a game where you're a skeleton who
throws your skull to stun and then you
punch stuff out and throw your skull
against and eat it up and literally put
meat on your bones by the way you can
collect power-ups like fire which does
well it does this the silly names don't
stop there go check out don't get your
pants where the title is your only goal
you type directions and try your best to
not make a mess in your pants
let's try check out Vsauce I don't know
how to check out Vsauce okay let's try
fart dang it
okay but trust me though there is a way
to win let's add an F and play shift in
this game you have to press the shift
key to invert the world the black ground
and white background reverse rolls so
you can creatively exploit the puzzle
world and reach the door most of you
have probably already played Mario
crossover it's an exact copy of Super
Mario Brothers except you can play as
other NES characters like Bill from
contra and even use their original
weapons and moves but look if you want
your mashups more trippy download and
install rom check fail this game is only
for PC and Linux but as you play the
world it glitches out between classic
arcade games and you have to just keep
plenty
it was created in three weeks during an
independent gaming competition the
Sagittarian is a point-and-click
adventure which quizzes you on your
ability to survive a zombie apocalypse
and as an even greater buzzkill this new
adventure game lets you make normal real
life decisions as if you were a
low-income family and if you can't pay
rent at the end of the game you're
homeless this is the only level is a
game that contains only one level which
you have to keep playing over and over
again with slightly different rules and
controls each time it starts off easy
and gets weirder and weirder finally
take a break from playing games and
listen to music
issuers guide is really old but if you
haven't used it yet it's awesome the
website gives you a graphical flowchart
of electronic music styles by decade and
influence and even lets you read about
and listen to samples from each genre I
bring it up because yesterday Jake
showed me map of metal calm here you can
browse well a map of metal also
organized by year genre and with an
incredible amount of songs for each
different style in the comments let me
know which exact sub-genre of music is
your personal favorite give specific and
check out all these interactive things
in the description if you do well come
back here and let us know how well you
did and let us know that you later the
pants okay I'm gonna fix that picture
but until next time thanks for watching